my name is Pascal balish a professor of
psychology and data science at NYU I'm
an expert in visual perception I'm here
to answer your questions from Twitter
this is optical illusion support
[Music]
and O'Malley oh nice username an anomaly
asks have you seen the optical illusion
where you stare at a spiral then look
away and things appear to be crawling
yes this is a a very striking example
it's called emotion after effect and you
take a look at this video here if you
look at the dot in the center it's 10
seconds or so and then look away I
recommend looking at your hand the hand
will appear like it is crawling and
what's going on here we actually
understand this very well there's been
thousands of studies on this over the
decades we know the neurons in your
brain that are underlying the perception
of motion once they get active for a
while they get tired they fired a lower
rate than they did before and and this
is not
um you know enter morphizing that you
can measure this with voltages in the
brain and we have user s bernian asks I
was staring at the spinning dance
illusion thing and she started spinning
backwards this goes viral on social
media every so often and let me be very
clear or early on every time this does
go viral people say oh if you see it's
spinning clockwise or counterclockwise
this will tell you whether you're like a
left brain or a right brain person and
I'm here to tell you no that has nothing
to do with that that is literally fake
news that is not true reasons you can
tell that is not true is that if you
look at this video you might notice that
Midway looking at it the dancer changes
the direction of motion so it was
clockwise before now it goes clock
counterclockwise and vice versa so
obviously nothing's changing stimulus if
you watch this again you will have a
different experience maybe the image
itself
is devoid of critical information so if
you the Contour
is just black so it's unclear if this
hand is in front or this hand is in
front so whether the dancer will spin
this way or that way will depend on your
assumption if you see the front hand or
the backhand yes and the way you can
switch this if you deliberately force
yourself to presume that one arm is the
front and one is the back this
highlights two important things one your
perception of the world is an
interpretation of the world and that
interpretation depends on the
assumptions that you make about the
world if there's not enough information
about the world this is a great one
Spiros lancos asks what is motion
induced blindness motion-induced
blindness is a great example of like how
important motion is so what you see in
the video is if you focus on the dot in
the middle and there's three yellow dots
that are always there if you keep
focusing it on the middle those dots in
the perfect start to disappear now I'm
claiming that they're always there they
never go away you can confirm that and
you can rewind the video but just by
keeping look looking at that so what's
going on here motion is very very strong
so this is not another example of how
your perception is the best guess of the
world so there's two competing models
now one is that there's three dots and
they're always there and one is a
rotating plane that's kind of occluding
those dots and in when in doubt your
brain will go to move to motion and I'm
actually now gonna ruin magic for you I
guess because most magic tricks rely on
this the idea is if I create some
distraction by you know move making a
lot of motion here I can do literally
anything else in plain sight and you
will not see it says the sea bass asks
can someone please explain the
difference between the five phenomenon
and beta motion to me and I'm happy to
help beta motion is happening right now
if you're seeing this on a on a device
and this is a video of me talking there
is no motion so you see I'm moving right
now but there's no motion you see uh
still images uh something like 30 or 60
or whatever the frame rate of your
monitor is a second your brain is
inferring the uh motion between that's
basically there's two objects first one
is object here and an object is here the
brain is filling in that something is
moving if something is here and it
disappears then something is here the
brain
concludes infers as an unconscious
inference a conclusion it's a guess it
didn't just was here and then it
disappeared that was here now it moved
that's the inference if you make this
fast enough uh 20 Hertz or 30 Hertz it
will appear like Smooth smooth motion
that's the beta motion what Phi is is
you have uh the objects static sometimes
in a ring and you have then some shadowy
thing occluding it it will appear like a
object is moving around them that's Phi
that's what Phi motion is colian asks
how do mirages happen so weird that is a
example of a genuine optical illusion
most things that are called optic
illusions are not optical illusions what
do I mean by that Optics means light
it's Greek for light so a mirage is an
example of an actual optical illusion in
contrast most of the other things we'll
see today are not optical illusions they
are visual Illusions the difference is
those are not in the light those are
created by your brain it usually happens
if there is you know air air that's
being heated by a service like for
instance a road and that is then hitting
a layer of air above it that's colder
and at that transition between the cold
air which is denser and the hot air
Which is less dense light will bend
that's what crazy Mirage next question
by
um Andrei Gomez emilson does it feel
like the dark parts are pushing
brightness onto the center and the white
is pushing out first of all this is
called the Asahi Illusion by kitoka what
I find is most striking about this is
that the center part here right does to
me and probably to you although it
depends on your screen look brighter
than the background white in the
background right can you see that and
it's not it's exact same whiteness in
the center than in the in the periphery
right so what is going on here is that
the gradients of luminance that are
pushing into the center as the poster
asks make you assume that you're looking
at something like the sun the size of
your pupil
is a reflex it dilates and constricts
depends on how much light is coming in
so if you look at a very bright uh as a
very bright uh light source like I'm now
looking into studio lights my pupils
will constrict research shows that if
you look at this illusion
of an image that's not brighter you
previously will also constrict which is
quite striking this is a reflex it's not
under conscious control John T Gardner
asks this is a pretty cool illusion does
the black hole look like it's expanding
to you and this was discovered uh this
year in 2022 and what was discovered was
two things number one seven out of eight
people report that yes the black hole
look like it's growing it's expanding
into the periphery second of all it's
also been shown that as if it was
actually getting darker your pupil is
dilating as if it was actually getting
darker so this is again uh stunning
because this is not under your conscious
control this is a reflex and it's
responding to your perception of the
image not to the actual light Lisa gato
2 asks is there an explanation for the
dress I was late now Lisa you are in
luck
I have the actual dress the dress itself
is unambiguously in bright light
black and blue yes we can all agree on
that it looks black and blue but that's
not what we were asking we were asking
was is the image of the dress black and
blue or white and gold if you ask that
most people will say two-thirds
according to our research we'll see this
this image as white and gold so what's
going on here the lighting information
in this image is ambiguous because it
was taken inside
but it was Overexposed on a cell phone
picture with a Samsung camera so in
other words it's unclear if this was
artificial lighting or uh outside
lighting natural lighting yes if there's
not enough information our brains
generally don't say I don't know they're
very immodest they will fill in the
missing information by making
assumptions about the world what
assumptions do you like about the
lighting depends on what experience of
light you have so what we could show in
our research is that people who are
morning people are more likely to see
the dress as white and gold whereas
night owls are more like suited as black
and blue and the reason for that is they
are assuming that illumination that they
have seen more of in their life and
mentally subtract that from the image
originally in 2015 when it came out
two-thirds of the people saw it as one
gold and one third so it's black blue
even though in real life it's
unambiguously 100 black and blue
Elizabeth crop asks how did they make
Tupac in hologram form well there's two
questions here first question is how do
Holograms work and how did they do this
specific one Holograms work
by having lasers to lasers
interfere with each other and lasers by
the way don't actually have one
wavelength they also have one phase
they're phase locked so therefore that
interference patterns you can then
reconstruct the entire image in other
words a genuine hologram will look 3D
from any perspective you look at it but
it will be somewhat monochromatic so
what I did in a two-pack case is
actually it's actually not a hologram
which is going to be very clear what
they did is something else that's called
uh as a version of peppers ghost where
you have a transparent screen at 45
degrees where you project previous
images or previous footage of Tupac onto
it that's an illusion if you look out of
that plane from a different perspective
from a different angle it would not not
look 3D like a genuine hologram would so
the two-part hologram was not a hologram
but yes Jeffrey asked has anyone
experienced The Wagon Wheel effect when
not watching TV or movies so first of
all what is the Wagon Wheel illusion
let's say you watch a car and they're
tired of spinning at a certain rate that
interacts with the sampling rate of the
camera if the frame rate of the wheels
spokes of the wheels of the car rims I
guess is faster than that and I call
aliasing it will actually look like it's
moving back backwards so basically
that's from the interaction between the
uh frame and the in the video and and
the in reality some people get that in
reality
without the camera
and this is to be honest with you a very
uh controversial subject because the
implication is that your mind has a
certain frame rate and certain people
might have a different framement than
other people which is why some people
might see it than others it's it's
really how tired you are or how well
rested you are might be also be an
individual difference but the
implications are profound because that
means your mind is running at a certain
frame rate and yeah I think that is true
different people's brains probably run
at different frequencies Cheryl ebuka
asks in a world full of confusion can we
really trust our eyes and that's a
wonderful question and I'll try to give
you a nuanced answer your brain does not
live in the outside world the brain is
encased fully in a bony shell in other
words it's extremely completely dark
what your perception is of the world is
ultimately just a guess
now to be fair
that guess is usually a very good guess
all of us got here without accidents you
usually navigate the world uh fine so in
other words usually your eyes are not
lying to you and the reason for that is
that billion years of evolution made
sure that if you're wrong by this guess
the punishment is could be death so this
has been debugged in a very Relentless
process over a billion years only a
stoner asks how real is reality our eyes
deceive us our brains trick us into
seeing faces our thoughts create
themselves and you think any drugs to
make shirt trippy username checks out
that is a really good point it is the
very existence of illusions that
illustrates the difference between what
you perceive and what is out there which
makes it clear that what looks to us
like reality is ultimately just a guess
even if the guess is pretty good what
Illusions are is a you know a way for
psychologists to show people that there
is a difference between what's out there
and what your best guess is I don't want
to
um
freak anyone out what this means is and
most people don't know this is that the
Matrix actually is a documentary it is
your brain that creates this Matrix for
you again this can be very feel very
claustrophobic because you're like okay
what is really out there you will see
motion when there's no motion you will
see color and there's no color you will
be confused about the spatial layout of
things and things like that so the
question is what actually is out there
Chris Lynn Todd asks I have written
often about the Moon Illusion which
makes the moon larger and it's close to
the Horizon does anyone know if the
Apollo Astronauts experience an earth
illusion first of all great question so
what the Moon Illusion is as the poster
asks is if you look at the Moon on the
horizon it will look considerably larger
than if you look at it high up in the
sky it's the same Moon as hard as that
possible when I was in grad school
a long time ago I read a very thick book
about a hundred theories of why the Moon
Illusion happens so this is still
unresolved what I find most compelling
is once the Moon is on the horizon you
have a local context in other words if
there is a hill or a mountain or a house
even it will make the Moon look really
really big because you know that the
house or the mountain is really really
big yes whereas if it's high up in the
sky then you have no reference point so
we'll it will look like it actually is
actually very small the Moon is only one
degree of visual angle something like
that would you get that on on the moon
and the answer is to my knowledge nobody
saw the Earth that low but my my
prediction would be yeah if you go to a
Moon crater and look at the Earth from
the advantage point you would get an
earth release Daniel Parker asks
adelson's Checker Shadow illusion hurts
my brain every time I look at it why
must you lie to me eyes Okay as you can
see here I think we can all agree that
the shade of gray in a looks different
than the sheet of gray and B even though
you that they are the exact same sugar
gray but even if you know that you
cannot see them like that you still will
see b as lighter than a what's going on
is that your brain is taking into
account the shadow that's coming off the
cylinder here and is mentally
subtracting that from the gray in B
which makes it look lighter why must the
eyes lie well the eyes must lie to you
because the image that the eye gets is
actually a very poor image the Optics
are bad the brain has to like kind of
like enhance the image for you to make
sense of the world so appearances can be
deceiving
Rich sweet asks is this Animal
Collective album cover moving or am I
tripping out and here it is a good
proportion of people will see motion
here but there is no motion and that's
what makes it so trippy you know that
there's no motion and you can actually
see that if you look at something
closely but you see things moving in
periphery this disconnect between your
perception of motion and you know
there's no motion it creates this trippy
feeling Tweety yaka asks does everyone
else get the Hermann grid illusion when
using their Mac keyboard or is it just
me the Herman grid is people see dark
spots illusory dark spots where bright
lines meet and you can see that we have
a Mac here I see that right now there's
a lot of bright lines and in this
intersection of those bright lines is a
dark spot that's that's not there that's
illusory that's that's the hermit this
is an example of it's called ladder
inhibition the idea is in the brain
neurons that are next to each other that
process a certain region of space
inhibit each other and the more the
active the more strongly the inhibit
their neighbor now if you're very
strongly inhibited by four strongly
active neighbors you're going to be
strongly inhibited it will appear darker
because it can inhibit the periphery
less Jessica pin asks does anyone know
what it means that I see the lines as
the same in the Miller liar illusion
here is the Middle Light illusion all of
these lines in the center are the same
length but most people will perceive
this one in the middle as longer than
this one most people but not everybody
sees that this actually happens to be
what I'm interested in my lab we study
uh individual differences in perception
what's going on here is that people take
the context into account when
interpreting the the scene I would bet
that you probably have experience with
like maybe you're like an artist or
something like that maybe you you can
see through uh what the appearance is
and you can recover like you can ignore
the context you know uh what what the
length of lens is so artists for
instance don't see the Middle Light
illusion so people have a lot of
experience with actual drawings they
will not be fooled by this breakdown
Paradise asks how do magic guy pictures
work so this is an example of where
people are inferring or minds are
inferring the third dimension from a
two-dimensional image it's called
stereopsis the two eyes see the image
slightly differently for slight
different perspectives but your brain
knows that so basically you can compute
if you see the same image slightly
differently
that there's actually a
three-dimensional depth to that this
distance has to be reconstructed in your
mind Eliza stuff asks how do 3D movies
work the idea is that two images are
presented so if you have like a colored
lenses so let's say one lens is uh
orange and one lens is blue so the red
will get through the orange lens but not
the blue that creates an offset and this
offset is the same idea we'll then
create the 3d effect Anna Cooper asks if
you have a really long aims room it's
the end limit to the extent of the
illusion could you have to crawl on your
hands and knees at one end of the room
yet slip through a gap in the skirting
board at the other so here's the aims
room so so you look at that through
peephole and looks like a normal Square
Room but it's not one of those ends will
be much farther than the other one but
it looks like they're on the same
distance away right by inference and if
you think you know that the same
distance way the one that is actually
farther in reality will then look larger
so the user asks a good question how far
can you push that and I'll put that
right back at the user let's find out
out because in reality we haven't tried
that that that's big ones the biggest
one was made in India in 2015 that's in
the Guinness Book of World Records but
that was not that big so why don't we
make a really big one to see when that
breaks down eventually of course the
curvature of the earth will swallow one
of the one of the people Lupine
Chevalier asks what is forced
perspective okay great so look at this
this is Ames window not Ames room this
appears to be a square window yes but
it's not it's a trapezoid in reality
so this actually is larger than this
this part is larger than this part but
because you know how perspective works
you will assume that this is farther
away even though it's not all of this
comes from the fact that you do not have
this third dimension available you have
to reconstruct it in your mind so it's
ambiguous if this is far away if this is
farther away so use your familiarity to
resolve that and you're familiar with
perspective every painting you look at
since the Renaissance uses effect where
you basically have a perspective so it's
a flat image it just looks far away if
it's deeper in Jim Rose circus asks my
niece asked me why is his pies a little
and now I can't see it yeah that is a
very good point most people of course
don't look at logos that closely but I'm
here to tell you that there is a bear in
the tobler Toblerone logo there's an
arrow in the FedEx logo once you saw
that you cannot unsee that so until your
dying day you will see this little man
here on the body of the KFC logo and
it's not just KFC I'm gonna ruin ducks
for you forever look at this duck all
ducks are wearing dog masks now that you
saw that you cannot unsee to what this
shows is that experience factors into uh
your perception just like an address
where like you probably experience with
a stimulus helps you resolve that's what
you see Noah Gerard asks I need to see
the Penrose stairs in person I can look
at it a million times and still not
fully understand the physics of it well
there's a reason for that this was
popularized by MC Escher and in this 3D
reality
this does not exist the pendo stairs are
just one example of uh what Tara aders
asks which is what is oblivid oblivit is
an impossible object and there are quite
a few of those and uh the whole point of
it is you can so for instance if someone
asks hey how many spikes are there three
there are 350 folks on this side or four
folks in this side who's right well
you're both wrong same question you can
ask is if I'm asking is this Slinky
although it's always good to have a
slinky on hand is this a circle
or is it a sine wave yes and the answer
is the 3D reality Slinky is both depends
on your perspective so your perspective
also determines what you see and so in
in this case the 3D reality transcends
both the circle or the spiral each ride
Arizona asks have you ever heard of the
age-old diet trick based on the the buff
illusion to use a smaller plate in order
to trick the brain into thinking you are
eating more than you actually are
there's a lot to unpack here first of
all what is the Dell buff illusion the
answer is a circle surrounded by a large
Circle as you can see here in the image
will appear larger than actually is the
answer is yes you can use that and yes
this does work and as research shows uh
weight control is all about it's not all
but it's a large part about portion
control again when we go back to whether
these Illusions are good or bad for you
you can use these Illusions
um for good absolutely Susan Wardle asks
why do we mistakenly see faces when
there are none this is a condition
that's called paradolia yes it is true
that most people see uh faces everywhere
many people see that perception is a
guess and the guess was debugged by
Evolution so if you're wrong you die in
other words if there's actually someone
out there who's trying to get to you and
you think there's nobody out to get you
you might die if there's no one and you
think there is someone might get a
little scared but that's fine the payoff
Matrix is vastly in favor of false
positives meaning thousands of false
Powers okay meaning seeing Facebook and
no faces but if you miss one actual face
an enemy
you might die
so the system is built to accept
thousands of false positives for one's
false negative all right that's it
that's all the Illusions we're time for
I hope you learned something useful see
you next time